I'm a low Tech girl in a high-tech world
but I surround myself with all these
people that are into that high-tech
world but I don't want to talk to
everybody that wants to talk to me I
don't text because I don't want to have
to answer if somebody calls me I'll I'll
answer if I want to talk to him or I'll
call him back when I can otherwise I got
too much to think about than to clutter
my mind up with everything else I'm
certainly not a stupid person I could
learn it if I wanted to but I rather
just have my fa machine call in my
creative stuff to my crew and I've got
the best crew in the world and I
surround myself with great people but I
just don't have time to just sit in my
face in phone all
day